it is not too late to summon that luck
of the irish and our friend brook fritz
from clover and steph is here to help us
bring some charm to saint patrick's day
welcome back thank you for having me i
love it i love this table talking about
bringing some of that saint patrick's
day charm to your kitchen or to your
table and if you have kids i i know my
children would love this tell us how you
can bring that to the table so i always
like to make every holiday a little bit
more exciting than maybe it might be st
patrick's day i've always tried to do
something fun with my kids to let them
know how much how lucky i am to have
them or how charming they are you know
play on words
they are to have you right
so anyways i always like to leave a
little something special for breakfast
in the morning and so instead of just
having rainbow cereal i would divide it
up and put it in a cute jar attach it
with a spoon
and put the milk in a cute container and
leave that on the counter so when they
wake up before they go to school they
have something exciting i mean it takes
a little extra time but it's still it's
it looks cool and it's like okay wow
yeah it's it's something special for you
yeah just something simple and special
and
another thing we used to do is we talked
about this oh yeah this have you ever
seen rainbow spaghetti never now you
have how how did we do this okay so this
is so simple you cook your pasta just
like you normally would okay and then
you get a large plastic bag and you
divvy up your pasta in the plastic bag
and you put about two drops of food
coloring and a little tiny bit of water
and then you just massage the pasta in
the bag and let it sit for five minutes
and while you have rainbow spaghetti put
your own sauce on it butter cheese
whatever how fun is that that my kids
would love that that is such a fun
activity no maybe you don't want them to
eat rainbow spaghetti you want them to
get some fruit yes this is this is an
easy and fun activity easy and fun
activity you can just take all your
fruit and instead of just putting it on
the platter just display it a little bit
like a rainbow and mercedes is adding
the clouds to the end of the rainbow
here with the donuts so this can be a
breakfast a breakfast item as well this
is nice because you got your healthy
fruits and then okay you can have a
little cloud you can have some little uh
donuts there
little donuts a little pasta
and
i love that isn't that fun so cute okay
what else do we have here um so these
are something really fun and simple to
do it's pretzel suckers they're
chocolate suckers and you can buy
chocolate in colors
and all i do is put some chocolate in a
plastic bag and i melt it in the
microwave for about 20 seconds
and you put it on a parchment piece of
paper and you just put a little dollop
of the chocolate and then you put the
pretzels on and then you have a little
shamrock sucker oh that is so something
simple
and then you have a quick little
activity here yes okay so we have um
some drinks to go along with your pasta
make it more fun and festive so we just
got some colored soda and then you could
take a little um
gummy okay
put it on your skewer
and create a little fun little rainbow
thing a little rainbow you add this you
kind of make it like lacy like put it on
back and forth back and forth like an
accordion and you can put that on
and then and then when you're done with
that add a little
poof of um
cotton candy and then voila putting it i
mean that's funny any kid would love to
have that i would love to have that i
would be like oh i would do that with a
little cocktail yeah yeah okay and
lastly we gotta do this because this is
a shamrock shamrock cake okay it's a
special cake
inside there's a surprise for you so
we're going to cut it open okay we'll
see how this goes
cut open the cake there's a surprise yes
okay what do we have here here's a
little plate open up the cake and oh
look at that there's little coins inside
all the little gold coins oh
bro
so cute thank you
from clover and stem thank you so much
for making our our st patrick's day even
more special
ideas how do people get in touch with
you find me at clover and stem or clover
and stem creatives oh you're the best
thank you we'll be right back